check this out so fox news democrats are
getting increasingly
nervous about woke culture analysts say
james carville says wokeness is a
problem and everyone knows it
interesting james i didn't see him you
know coming out and speaking about this
before the election why say whatever
they have to say to gain power
now that they realize there's a
competing power hungry fascistic
ideology
now they're worried about it but many of
these woke leftists
aligned themselves with neocons and
neolibs because orange men bad
many many leftists democratic socialists
also aligned themselves what a truly
powerful coalition of people who have no
business supporting each other
just because they hated trump they were
able to form that alliance now trump is
gone now it's all falling apart
but but the wokeness is uh a very very
real problem for democrats because it's
starting to supplant the establishment
they're forced to adopt a lot of this
nonsense a lot of this ridiculous
rhetoric
and joe biden is the epitome epitome of
old white men
somehow they got the woke to vote for
him but now they're recognizing it's
going to cause them increasing
increasing problems moving forward with
with these elections joe biden's always
been woke joe biden is the one that
kicked off the title ix reform that
stripped away due process
for men and people anyone accused of
harassment on campus because he believed
the sjws who went in there crying about
rape crisis rape one and four one in
four
it was joe biden himself who pushed the
2011 thing
which really opened up the floodgates
for all this woke crap to get into for
all the administrative elements of our
universities
from there they trained all these
students who went into the corporations
and now they're transforming the
corporations
so really joe biden has been the avatar
of woke the leader of woke
the biggest enabler of woke since
as far back as i can remember in the
early parts of the obama administration
which is totally ironic given his past
comments and his beliefs about
segregation in schools and all these
things it's it's interesting
but he's always been a tool for them and
man it's guys like andrew sullivan
man that burns me up i know because
andrew sullivan correctly identifies the
problem with woke
he understands critical race theory is a
problem he understands the racism he
understands how it turns into
anti-semitism
he didn't care all he wanted to do was
get rid of trump
yep he did not care he is supposed to be
somebody with some sense of reason like
a sane voice out there at least that's
how i remember him
when i was a kid and i wasn't too
politically informed but i would watch
him on bill maher and i'd be like
well he's the conservative one and i
like him better than all the rest of
them
so i remember him and i remember him
writing an article in 2000 about
testosterone replacement therapy
where he acknowledges the power of
hormones in driving personality and
behavior and expression of self etc
so he understands and has known for a
long time but he was unwilling
to stand up for it he was willing to
support
and advocate for joe biden to accept the
wokeness
simply to get rid of donald trump and
for that man
just sacrifice everybody burn it down
because this guy's got mean tweets
mean tweets good policies good policies
but mean tweets
oh but mean tweets man i know hey what
am i gonna tell my kids
you know he he tweeted that that lady
was a horse face of course
that was funny actually rosie o'donnell
wasn't that woody on you period
oh my gosh he called he called stormy
horseface he tweeted that right he did
wow he did hilarious yeah
but you know mean tweets mean tweets bad
but hey like what double the amount of
kids kept in cages on the border right
now
how much is the increase the surge of
people who are from streaming across the
border
it's it's it's literally the spongebob
meme dude where patrick and spongebob
are like
the city's on fire and pat and
spongebob's like we did it we saved the
city that's that's what it is
yeah they they they trump represented
something
you know it was it was a clever play by
the establishment they did it
there was a combination of milking media
and uh the democrats being like we want
to win so we'll we'll do whatever we
have to do
and it started before he even took
office oh yeah it was nuts it was nuts
before he got it so so i wanted to
mention i saw this really funny video
from babylon b
where it's a bunch of clan members and
they're discussing like
how like hey the media is saying like
you know racism is back in so like it's
time to get back in the game
and then one of them is like no no you
don't got to do anything anymore you're
a white male
just literally just be and you're racist
you're you're
good and then the the leader of the
dragon he's like he's like what what do
you mean he's like no i want things
and then he starts naming things and
they're like yeah but that's not racist
anymore
to say this so he was like what about
segregation like no no no the left says
that's good now so it ends with this
clan member
like going to a university and demanding
segregated water fountains
and then a woke guy walks up and goes
that's really forward thinking man i
respect that
that's that's that's like that's where
we are that's where we are i saw an
interview with uh christopher ruffo on
oh mark lamont hill on vermont hello i
saw that okay
and lamont hill tried to mark right
whatever
he tried to back
and bait roofo into answering a question
that would have would have broken his
frame and the question it was like
well can you say anything nice about
white people no no hold on hold on
rufo said that this critical race theory
is
is attacking what they describe as
whiteness saying it's a very negative
thing we shouldn't be doing that yes and
then he said
oh okay if if uh if you think they're
saying it's a negative thing then what's
one thing you like about being a white
man right and rufo
said i you know i i don't see it that
way i don't agree with that and so then
he goes no no just humor me just humor
me
and then rufus said i reject the premise
of
of your claims about whiteness and i
want you to treat me like an individual
as much as you know i would treat you
and then he tweeted something ruffo
tweets something that was brilliant
he responded to marcelo hill saying you
and i have substantially more in common
the same language the same country
much you know uh say like similar income
level in class
more so than i would have in common with
a swedish farmer
and more so than you would have with a
nigerian farmer
that's that that was an amazing point
that he made about wokeness and critical
race theory
that i think most of us already realize
obvious right because of what they're
not
they're not attacking whiteness they're
just calling it that they're just
attacking american culture
period that's it yeah my favorite thing
was like
what what did what did rufo say he said
okay well if i have to
you know use critical race theory then
perhaps being on time and working hard
and then a bunch of people on twitter
like no one defines whiteness that way
i saw i was right there on all that and
so this this is absolutely produced they
do though
they do though they do define that
that's exactly how they define it oh
there's absolutely no question that
white supremacy white dominance culture
is defined by punctuality reliance on
data self-reliance individualism rugged
individualism
objectivity science all kinds of things
right
a desire to be safe yeah right
but it brings up an interesting point um
chris you know i love you chris i've had
chris on the show a number of times he's
a tremendous guy
he he has a he has a role that he's
playing he's
incredibly effective and he's got huge
amounts of change
i am a little bit different than him i
might have actually doubled down
when they asked that question i would
have been like hell yeah i love a
million things about being white i love
being on time i love being myself
i love taking care of myself and being
responsible for everything about me and
not needing handouts whatever yeah but
that's interracial marriage
that's not going to work because the the
general audience doesn't know anything
about it
so if you come out as this you know
indeed they don't know anything about it
they also didn't know anything about it
when chris answered the way he did at
least the way
that i would have done it is a very
tried and proven
technique called agree and amplified
when someone asks you a question that's
clearly meant to be provocative or to
challenge you
the only response is to take what
they're accusing you of
and just come back and say yes times 10.
so what i would do
is i would pull up the african-american
heritage museum and i would say
well not that i agree with your view
mark which i believe is a white
supremacist worldview but i did pull up
this article from the african-american
heritage museum which says
that being on time is a trait of
whiteness yeah see i reject that premise
but based on your you want me to humor
your ideology your white supremacist
ideology
oh i would agree with you on that i
suppose that being on time is a good
thing
i would however disagree that it's
whiteness to be on time because i'm
pretty sure you are on time
the funniest part of all right is like
that guy
is punctual takes care of himself he
doesn't want a handout doesn't want
anybody to help him he believes in the
power of personal effort and
responsibility
and data you don't think that guy's
looking at ratings
louise so the whole thing is absurd and
it's like i'm ready just to agree on
amplify now
today on twitter i was like crt is
absolutely right man
with this white culture this is what it
is and it's great and it's the best
culture that it is and look what it's
created and here we are
i agree it's it's it's it's look just
google search critical theory i know and
this thing that you reference about the
american african-american heritage
museum
the last thing on that they took it down
right because it was so
insane that it was like a clan like a
clan member it was insane that our
federal tax money paid for this thing
and was publicly posted by the
government where since the 90s
where the last thing about
anti-racist is i yield
positions of power to people of color
that is what they want specifically
in the literature you white person yield
your position to you
person of color why to take care of
history and all these terrible things
and blah blah blah
and because you've got your power and
you don't so you have to get out of the
way that's what they're teaching your
kids
that's what they're teaching your
children in school i mean it's a it's
it's
step aside beyond grace do you want your
children to be told to yield positions
of power that they may have earned
through hard work and dedication
perhaps i'm getting hot it's well beyond
race though this is one of the issues i
have with the constant saying critical
race theory over and over again
is that critical theory is much larger
than that right it's it
it encompasses science
they say science isn't real so we say
critical race theory we say critical
race theorists believe there's no
critical
theorists believe this and it's it's
much much more than just race right
they tell your kids that two plus two
equals five
yeah what are they going to do now that
it's becoming evident that they actually
are the institutional power they're
going to have to
eject half of their philosophical
background because
it's specifically about attacking people
in power no no they don't
they they don't because they come out
they say it and
cowards regular americans are who are
cowards just accept it even though they
know they have institutional power come
on hollywood is not
pressed hollywood's opinions the
democrats are not oppressed you're
missing my point i'm talking about the
philosophical underpinning
the reference has always been a lie
always been a lie
so when they come out and they say we're
still oppressed oh come on they were
claiming
donald trump as the power structure of
this country just donald trump whose own
staff
he had hired people who hated him john
bolton hated him he hired a bunch of
idiots he should have fired a bunch of
other idiots and he had no control over
cultural institutions so you had every
news organization except fox news
even sometimes fox news you had the
republican establishment opposed to him
of the democratic establishment
hollywood
you had all the major corporations and
they claimed trump was the power yeah
yeah no i agree we're talking about two
different things
i totally i understand you're saying the
philosophy but my point is
they had they came out at a time when
they already were
the institutional authority in every
respect and said
we're the marginalized now there's been
a slight change
a few seats have flipped in congress and
now they're still saying the same thing
well right but
but this is this is a 50-year process
right so these changes about them
actually taking over institutional
control
are really in like the eighth and ninth
inning of this game that's already been
going on for a long time
so all my whole my only point here is
that the hypocrisy that you're pointing
out
is just becoming a little bit more
obvious a little bit more evident
and that when they use their
philosophical studies in literature to
justify what they're doing
they're actually going to have to eject
part of the foundation that they've been
using
as justification for their actions which
is demonstration of the fact that it was
all bullcrap
in the first place and we're going to
see that i think moving forward
they don't have to eject the philosophy
okay
why would they have to i'm talking about
the theorists and the people that the
academics and the ones that write papers
based on papers based on papers with
references and such
but but what i don't understand is that
they've been lying the whole time so why
would they change anything
good point don't know they
they they control the colleges the
movies the tv shows
the political establishment the banking
institutions now the federal reserve is
woke
numerous federal reserve banks are now
embracing wokeness
joe biden is doing race-based rep
race-based recovery acts let's say
reparations
they just flaunt it while still saying
that the homeless white veteran sleeping
in the gutter is the oppressor
and oprah winfrey is oppressed it's
always been ludicrous on its face
it's just an excuse to manipulate the
emotions of dumb people who don't pay
attention
and you know what i'll give a special
shout out to bill burr who exemplified
this so perfectly
when he was on the joe rogan experience
and he was like
i'm not gonna do this with you joe sit
here with you who has no medical degree
and i have no medical medical degree
talking about what we should do
i turn on the tv once every two weeks
and i and i do what the tv says
thank you yeah he's so so smart
disturbing did you see him on conan a
few days
ago no some really really obnoxious
stuff
he exemplifies the problem i don't care
about this country
i don't care about this planet i don't
care about you i'm just gonna turn the
tv on once every two weeks and do what
it tells me to do
talk about giving up your responsibility
talk about being a wealthy dude
extracting from the system and saying fu
to all the hard working people who are
like please help us
this the room's on fire and he's like i
don't know i come in once every two
weeks and i do it the guy the door tells
me
he said he wished more people had died
from covet on conan what
was like what it was really disturbing
and he was like yeah you know the stupid
like like it was really really he's
allowed to make jokes it wasn't
i mean it wasn't funny what everybody
was saying was ridiculous you know
when when he's when he's exemplifying
one of the biggest problems in this
country
and that's regular people say i don't
know i don't care i don't want to know
and i don't want to care
and then it's like okay then what do
they do they
punch each other in the parking lot over
a can of beans they they there was a
when the gas shortage hit a video of a
guy
of a guy punching him in the face bro do
you see this
this is what happens when you ignore
everything i was talking about this the
other day several times now with fouchy
friends let's give you a good i'll give
you a good example
fauci goes on the tv and he's like you
don't need to be wearing masks you know
if you it might protect you from a
droplet or two
and then later a few months later he's
like oh i lied on purpose because we
wanted doctors to get it
and so my point was if fauci came out
and said just wear a scarf
people would have worn scarves but he
was worried doctors wouldn't get masks
but if people just wore scarves and
masks then the doctors would have
not have needed as many masks the point
is because no one paid attention to what
this
[ __ ] was saying they they ignored
sound policy when you had when you had
china buying up all the ppe
you had fauci be like no don't do it and
then people died
and then the doctors now need more masks
if people were paying attention
they wouldn't be fighting each other in
the parking lot for a can of beans
or punching somebody for some toilet
paper instead
they don't care they don't accept their
responsibility and they just
they just ignore it and then we we sit
here watching the place burn down it's
like we're in the titanic it's sinking
and we're like yo we need help and
they're like nah i'm good
bill imagine this your boat sinking
right you're on a big ship it's filling
with water and you're like you know what
it's a slow leak it's getting faster but
if everybody bails water we're gonna
make it
and then bill burr walks in and goes
look i just walk in the room once every
two weeks
and i look at the guy who's sitting in
the in the captain scene just do what he
tells me and the guy in the captain see
fouch he's just saying random stuff you
don't even know what he's talking about
so this guy then goes that's the
attitude all these americans have
we we have seen with the culture war
with gamergate with critical race theory
we have all been watching this happen
since the early 2010 since the late
to you know you look at the data from
zach goldberg and alexis and lexisnexis
and you can see the the massive
explosion of critical race theory and
then we start you know ringing the bells
and people say shut up i don't care the
media lies for sure yeah manipulates
people
but it really comes down to this if
people
just say i'll turn the tv on once every
two weeks and do what it tells me
then it doesn't matter what we know
these people keep voting for this stuff
i have friends
who i want one friend of mine he films
himself walking with like a fur
a pov shot of the ballot going to the
mailbox saying you've got to do what's
right for this country and vote for joe
biden
and when i said what does that mean vote
for joe biden he's just like
well you know trump's bad why is trump
bad what policy what are you talking
about he doesn't have any
he doesn't have it he turns the tv on
once every two weeks they say orange man
bed every time so he says okay
i'll go do what i have to do burn the
country down and throw another
another molotov cocktail into our
buildings our capital buildings our
institutions
and then come and complain that me with
the water i'm the problem
it's they called the the plebeians the
plebians is that what they were called
ancient rome
i was just watching this this reconquest
of the roman empire by um
uh what was that emperor's name but
anyway he went around and and
reconquered most of the empire they've
been flying around 250 a.d
most of people didn't care the citizens
of the cities they just they just
changed their flag they'd be like oh
okay a new a new leader take the old
flag down but they didn't want to die
they didn't want to get conquered they
don't want to get hurt
they just go along with it that's like
98 of the people
i have i have a lot of sympathy for
people that don't have the luxury that
we have of spending time
figuring this stuff out every day and it
is
very common and totally reasonable for
people
to not have that much time to dedicate
to processing consuming information
and this is why we're in such a
critically dire
circumstance because most people don't
even check in with the news because they
can't
because they're working hard they're
trying to figure out how to feed their
three kids and deal with virtual school
and go to work and deal with gas
shortages and deal with corona and all
these things
it's hard enough but it's getting to the
point where
the institutions are so corrupted that
there's
zero reason to trust there was reason to
trust
so we're at this part where there's like
this uh tectonic
uh pressure building where it's like oh
it was okay to be ignorant
and rationally ignorant over here
because everything was okay and
moving in this direction is it's lethal
now to be rationally ignorant
and it's kind of there's faults
happening there's little faults
happening
sooner or later there's going to be an
eruption if this thing turns out
muhan institute of virology and fauci's
involved
in advance to function or who know i
don't know what i'm talking about
the point is is like if this if there's
a real huge
massive scandal that comes out of this
it may wake some people up but i still
don't know
how to solve the problem for the dual
working
family with multiple kids and 50
different after school activities
and group think and just not having the
luxury of time to dedicate
i deal with this with my next wife all
the time because we're talking about all
kinds of issues
and she's like well how do you know it's
my job to know
i literally get paid every day to learn
and figure this stuff out
break it down synthesize it and then
explain it to people
it's my job let's i'm lucky for that
let's talk about the
the real world ramifications for for you
and your loved ones so uh i i agree
with with jack so uh for those just
tuning in we were talking about
you know people who don't pay attention
to the news and you made a good point
that i've often brought up it's not the
job of the average person to focus on
news and politics
a carpenter's job is to build thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time